so are you guys familiar with a guy
called mr beast
no wow how about you you don't know mr b
that's amazing that's amazing so we're
gonna let's by the end of this you're
gonna know who this guy is so this guy
his name is mr beast he's the
highest earning youtuber
of all time this guy you've seen him
before no
i don't know
i just met like him exactly that guy
right there his name is jimmy donaldson
he's 23 years old he earned 54
million dollars in a year in 2021 that
was the most of any youtuber in the
history
of youtube let's get a couple of stats
um
so he's 23 years by the way 23 years old
he made 54
million bucks in 2021 insanity he's 23
he went from 50 million subscribers to
90 million subscribers just in 2021 okay
how long has he been at it
he's since day one since day one at
least 10 years i don't know how long
exactly yeah when he was 13. yeah
exactly he racked up yeah like a kid he
racked up 10 billion views this year
um by the way 54 just as far as like how
big youtube is getting 54 million
doubled what last year's number one
order did you ever see this kid ryan's
world the little kid oh my goodness yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's like eight years old making twenty
five million dollars
he's the kind of kid that's like hey mom
and dad get me a coffee and shut your
stupid face
dude that's the modern day uh macaulay
is he the second most
he uh
was i think he finished no he's not
second and we're going to have you guess
whose second was he finished in the top
10 again this year uh the kid's slacking
i think he only made like 25 million
what a loser that 10 year old and we're
just talking youtube right we're just
talking youtube here so
uh getting back to mr bc is the third
largest uh us-based channel eighth
largest in the world so what does that
mean there's people with more followers
but they're not monetizing like this
dude he's eating gold ice cream right
here can you i mean i don't know if we
can switch out to see what does he do
specifically on youtube so exactly thank
you for asking ridiculous wild stunts so
what was the biggest show on netflix
this year
anyone know squid game something called
squid again thank you david for the win
yeah so basically he reenacted squid
game like full on made a whole
um
episode about people and he actually
killed people he was a bird
yeah yeah david blood yes
but basically he'll spend millions
millions and millions to create to
produce i mean clearly this is called
roi he'll spend two million bucks on a
video right to make three million you
see what i'm saying you made 54 million
dollars ridiculous so
he spent uh another couple of you asked
what he did jenny uh he spent 50 hours
buried alive
just to see what that's like he gave
people uh cat 10 grand to basically go
in a bathtub of snakes he's giving away
money left and right this guy this guy
right here 24 hours underwater or
something it was
he's done something what else has he
done what else is he doing i don't know
that was the only one okay
but so just to put it in perspective
like your mid-20s your mid
20s ish we're like a year apart okay you
guys
we're gonna get into how you guys know
each other as well
um 40
i didn't know him before i started doing
youtube content so you guys don't even
know him my eight-year-old nine-year-old
nephew is up to mr beast oh my god like
kids flip over this stuff and he's
watching him bury himself alive which
now that you say that i think that's why
there's such an increase because now
kids back then we weren't on tablets
like that
this new generation they're growing up
on tablets so the kids are the ones that
are making these youtubers really
exactly when you were little you
probably want to be on tv right oh yeah
i was i was watching mtv music videos
yeah we were gonna be on stage exactly
and they both turned into professional
dancers there you go
my niece and nephew same thing their tv
is their ipad exactly yeah i want to be
on that thing i think right yeah that's
that's the new way these kids these days
david let's hear kids these days
okay so basically he said look i got
this ridiculous platform i'm making
money on youtube clearly but he said
that ain't enough for me baby and then
he said all right i'm gonna start this
mr beast burger restaurant basically so
he partnered with so he's an
entrepreneur he's partnered with like i
think 1600 uh restaurants across the
country sixteen hundred yeah and he sold
uh five million burgers and he split the
profits of the restaurant so basically
they'll like burger joints will put a
beast burger mystery it's not his own
restaurant no no no no he's partnered
with sixteen hundred restaurants they
added a mr beast burger he's promoting
the hell out of it on his social
platforms boom made five million bucks
okay
um sold five million burgers i don't
know exactly how much you made from that
but he made a lot of money from that so
here you girls are very in the know you
guys are very into pop culture how about
this this this is who he made more money
than this year uh you ever heard of kim
kardashian
made more money than her you ever heard
of billy eilish made more money than her
you ever heard of angelina jolie yeah
made more money than her the group bts
the south korean pop-in
like they're like the biggest group in
the world a group of people exactly you
made more than that that's how much
money this guy is freaking making so
with that being said
what are your thoughts on this guy you
had never heard of him jenny
i mean he's killing the game he's not in
the game he figured out his lane figured
out how to monetize what we were talking
about earlier and created a path for
himself so i mean kudos to him but it's
also just about how how much our culture
is changing and what we deem as
entertainment before like the trash was
just reality shows right that was
considered trashing that's what kim
kardashian now is a higher level of
entertainment than this guy who's just
doing challenges and i think like that's
what's appealing to people they like
seeing a regular person not a celebrity
because they feel that they could i when
i grew up i didn't think i could be
jennifer aniston she was like another
level of person but when you see these
influencers and they're just coming to
talking to you from their house you feel
like you can become them very easily and
especially when you can get a hundred
thousand followers on tick tock and
you're 13. by the way uh
uh this is going to come off a little uh
you know rude maybe he's killing the
game there's nothing special about this
guy meaning he's not that's what i mean
he's not he's not good-looking he's not
hilarious he's not engaged he's just
he's dedicated to this so if there's
anything i can say about him like he
goes all
in on this and he's become an expert i
don't think there's like he was never
gonna make it in hollywood the only way
that this guy was gonna make money like
this was in something like this but
that's what even in the entertainment
industry the best singer doesn't make it
the best the most good looking person
doesn't make it it's your it's your
drive it's your your work ethic like
what are you willing to put in it's not
about the most talented it's about the
hardest worker but it's weird because we
grew up being like if you were talented
in a thing
you would be you would want if you're a
great singer you'd be a singer but these
people he wanted to be famous yes he
didn't have a
i think he uh started creating content i
actually agree well for what for his
health what exactly he's famous no but
maybe it was because he has fun like
maybe he doesn't naturally and he's like
he does it for the fun people there's
always a benefit he has to enjoy what he
does i'm sorry he's not spending
millions on this if he doesn't enjoy a
hundred percent sure but he also don't
get shanked by jenny okay you don't want
that no but i totally agree yeah that
hasn't come on oh he loves the fun
but he also loves the fame and like all
the money that comes from the views
the attention even that's the driving
force that's why i'm here
but when he started he didn't have that
true but that's what he was chasing
but how do you know that by the way
here's the lesson here's the lesson
everybody these days wants to get rich
quick we're going to talk about crypto
today oh my god dogecoin like everyone
wants to do this this guy's been doing
this for a decade and i guarantee you
when he first started doing the content
he was getting a hundred views right a
thousand views now a video he does will
get a hundred million views so what's
the lesson there it's like if you're
into something stick at it consistency
persistency attitude stick it out boom
this average joe right here is making 54
million bucks more than kim k billy
island and half these celebrities right
there so here's my question to you guys
you see a guy like that
he's not worth any money do you give
that guy a second chance
i'm guessing no and david was yeah but
he doesn't have any money he has no
money you look at that guy
you heard my first reaction get more
this guy
show me show more pictures show more
pictures yeah i need to see more okay
but jenny's not open it doesn't get any
better it's not getting it that's
actually a flattering picture for him uh
i think he's like 6'4 by the way i don't
know if that does anything for you by
the way knowing how much money he's got
right now does that change your attitude
on this guy not not even a little bit
not even a little bit what to do marius
how could you reject that smile
look at him hey second chance he's jenny
he's hideous
he's not ugly look at that
okay
54 million he hasn't goes a long way for
sure for me no it's not about for me i
don't care about the money but yeah i
know i need personality i need to know
how you make me feel but you know what
dating this guy means being a part of
their show
there's no chance you would want to be
mrs beast if i have to go underwater for
24 hours i don't know mrs beast in the
house all right okay we all agree
respect to this guy for doing his thing
right for sure he's the king of youtube
right now 54 million he's number one
respect to you buddy mr beast no
disrespect you're killing the game okay
by the way he's number one
you